[Musique]
imaginez la scène suivante vous êtes
célibataire avec d'autres célibataires
et on va vous présenter des prétendants
quand le gong retentit rare il faut
mettre le grappin sur la bonne personne
alors deux choses peuvent se produire
dans le meilleur des mondes chacun
chacune en fouillant en soit on va
trouver immédiatement la personne qui
lui faut et les célibataires vont se
répartir uniformément sur les
prétendants dans un monde plus
pessimistes auquel malheureusement je
crois les célibataires vont se
concentrer sur une poignée de
prétendants la majorité des gens n'ont
pas trouvé chaussure à leur pied
cette réalité c'est celle aujourd'hui je
pense du monde du travail
quand on conseille suis ta passion des
collégiens qui vont choisir leur
carrière ou à des adultes en
reconversion on le fait avec les
meilleures intentions du monde
on pense que comme dans l'histoire des
célibataires
chacun chacune va trouver son
originalité il va aller vers le métier
qu'il lui faut mais en vérité surtout en
matière d'apparence on désire un peu
tous les mêmes choses une étude de l
ocde 2020 montre que plus de la moitié
des collégiens rêve des dix même métier
et le choix qu'on est encore plus
restreint si on sépare ces collégiens
par sexe ont paru origines socio
économique des parents
j'en ai fait l'amère expérience lors de
mes de mes premières expériences
professionnelles dans le champ
prestigieux des fusions acquisitions
j'ai découvert que je n'étais pas seul à
avoir cette envie et cette idée que
j'étais avec des clones de moi même est
ce que ça signifiait concrètement c'est
que si j'avais la moindre exigence le
moins de désir d'originalité le souhait
de personnaliser quelque chose dans mon
quotidien au travail on pouvait
facilement me répondre que neuf autres
personnes telles que moi attendaient
pour le poste
d'autres de mes amis faisait à ce moment
là le même constat ils m'ont proposé de
construire notre métier de devenir
entrepreneur
sauf qu'on a fait à nouveau l'erreur on
a suivi notre passion on a cherché en
haut une idée qui nous ressemble on a
accouché d'un projet dans le jeu vidéo
et on s'est retrouvé face à trois autres
équipes qui elles aussi nous ressembler
et avait eu la même idée
alors on n'a pas abandonné l'idée de
construire notre métier mais on s'est
dit que cette fois ci plutôt que de
chercher en nous on allait mener une
enquête dans le monde et posez la
question autour de nous quels sont vos
besoins
qu'est ce qui vous manque quelles
compétences seraient nécessaires à votre
équipe
on a trouvé une idée une idée qui nous
ressemblait pas à priori avec un avec un
voile qui n'était pas une apparence qui
était pas la plus attirante mais on a
fait l'effort de persévérer de voir
s'ils avaient quelque chose
d'intéressant d'arrière alors avance
rapide ça c'est moi deux ans plus tard
je suis en train de reconditionner des
déchets radioactifs dans un institut de
recherche donc là c'est le moment de mon
histoire vous vous dites donc c'est ça
l'alternativa suis ta passion je préfère
sur ma passion mais peut-être là encore
qu'on s'arrête voile aux apparences du
métier moi même au premier abord
j'avais même réaction vous mais j'ai
creusé des semaines et des mois
j'ai parlé à des gens passionnés des
gens du métier et j'ai découvert trois
choses que je cherchais dans ma vie
professionnelle
l'excellence c'est un métier qui comme
tous les métiers où il ya la fois le
risque et à haut niveau technique ne
peut tolérer de vous que votre maximum
que 100% de vigilance tout le temps ils
vous tirent vers le haut sa métier
d'humanité de travail d'équipé parce que
vous ne pouvez pas concentré sur une
personne tous les savoirs nécessaires en
électronique en physique et les
compétences juridiques et vous allez
devoir vous entourer de gens en qui vous
avez profondément confiance parce que
vous allez prendre des risques ensemble
j'ai encore beaucoup d'amis de cette
période
et puis c'est un métier d'histoire une
bonne partie des informations liées au
nucléaire ne se trouve pas sur internet
elles sont dans des archives
jauni elles sont parfois dans la
tradition orale
j'ai la chance d'être formé par un
scientifique qui a contribué au début du
nucléaire français est d'avoir une
formidable amitié trans-générationnel
dans ce métier un métier d'histoire
aussi parce que les déchets ont une vie
une origine dans la mission qu'on voit
ici je me suis assis un jour par erreur
sur le bureau de marie curie qui étaient
contaminés alors ma carrière a connu des
rebondissements j'ai été de nouveau
salarié plein nouveaux entrepreneurs
mais j'ai gardé cette boussole en tête
de chercher autant si ce n'est plus que
dans mes désirs dans les besoins du
monde dans les secteurs les métiers les
rôles qui ne trouve pas suffisamment de
talents aujourd'hui
maintenant je suis formateur en
management
c'est un métier que j'adore pour plein
de raisons et une partie de mon métier
consiste à aider mes clients à
restructurer le quotidien professionnel
pour qu'ils soient plus enrichissant et
ça a renforcé ma conviction j'ai réalisé
que ceux et celles qui avaient ce
pouvoir sur leur quotidien professionnel
qui pouvait dire moi j'ai envie de
devenir un no man digitales et de
travailler depuis l'étranger moi j'ai
envie d'art des horaires flexibles
moi j'ai envie d'injecter ma créativité
qui je suis dans ce que je fais au
quotidien
ceux et celles qui ont cette chance
c'est souvent ceux et celles dont on ne
peut pas se passer qui ont une
compétence rare utile difficilement
remplaçable alors peut-être que dans la
recherche de sa vocation il faudrait
parfois accepté de construire sa passion
plutôt que je cherchais un coup de
foudre immédiat au travail quand mon
amour le prince charmant n'est pas
toujours le plus beau et ça peut valoir
le coup d'embrasser le crapaud
[Musique]